Harvey Weinstein was once the king of
Hollywood a man with the power to make
and break careers and a man who abused
that power he said welcome to the
Miramax family dozens of women have told
their stories among them Catherine
Kendall Larisa Gomez publicly Caitlyn
Delaney the assaults they allege
happened too long ago to result in
criminal charges but they see
vindication in his conviction is justice
it's it's what should be and it gives me
help hope you know for the future it
feels incredible it feels like one piece
of this terrible ordeal for so many
women so many people involved is at
least in one aspect put to rest so it
feels it feels like a victory feels like
justice is served as of five years ago
it was still a secret basically and to
think that now all these women have come
forward in the world as is taking note
and that he's actually facing you know
jail time is it means that we've really
come a long way
I don't think Harvey Weinstein ever
thought he'd see this day he did
everything in his power to keep it away
were the catalyst for this huge movement
the me to movement is bringing about a
lot of change a lot of conversation
about sexual assault about equity for
women and I'm grateful that my speaking
out along with these women has made a
difference it's kind of a moment of a
surge of reckoning in a way there's a
public dissection and of all of the
different aspects of sexual violence
abuse of power a woman should never be
afraid to be alone with a man being a
teacher
the male plumber that comes to your
house and mean the list goes on and on
there is we're just cultivating more
fear and then it's on the woman and we
have to just go around you know
terrified we're gonna be raped
everywhere we go that's that's not
that's not okay that's not right at all
not only did he commit these crimes he
got away with them for so long and he
harmed so many of us I mean it's
horrific if you think about it he think
about this little piece of history it's
hundreds of women we have finally been
heard and believed and that is worth
everything and I also think it will send
a message to perpetrators everywhere
that consequences are real what do you
think of Harvey Weinstein now I'm very
angry at Harvey Weinstein because this
man assaulted me and got away with it so
many years ago and I'm angry that he
assaulted so many women I'm angry for
every single one of them I think he's
just disgusting vile criminal
all along Harvey Weinstein has denied
these allegations but it doesn't end
here for him he now faces another trial
in Los Angeles a city and an industry he
once ruled now the stage for the
continuing story of his fall from grace
Gregg Milam Sky News